petit questionnaire monsieur rovinescu
verre à moitié plein ou verre à moitié
vide ou à moitié plein tout le temps
moitié plein tout le temps à côté c'est
le positif optimiste optimistes a
expliqué mentalité immigrants toujours
optimiste mais un peu paranoïaque
justin qu'ex new york ou paris carine
pourquoi tahri écouter une york j'adore
venir que ni aucune ville important
d'acteurs tous à paris mélange de
loisirs en plus que à belvis sauf que
mon fils avait tenu à maintenant donc
probablement j'irai tendance à niort
aujourd'hui avant paris mais paris
toronto ou montréal
écoutez ça c'est une set-top classique
qui veut des mamans réagi vite et
toujours à montréal sophie 3 ans en
angleterre
je dirais que je peux vivre ma vie
n'importe où mais j'adore ça à montréal
le l'aspect multiculturel qu'on a ici
remarquable on trouve ça très il ya très
très peu de villes comme ça bien entrer
dans les différentes communautés pour
moi c'était toujours un plaisir et
j'adore ça ou partez en vacances avec
une compagnies aériennes comme air
canada par exemple neige neige au soleil
ça c'était une question plus compliqué
de répondre je dirais probablement
soleil
j'ai je suis joue beaucoup dans la neige
quand j'ai le temps d'un week end et
tout ça donc probablement soler et il ya
plusieurs endroits intéressants au monde
que j'ai pas encore visité croyez le ou
pas exactement ce qui pousse pas ce qui
ce qui définitive oui je sais pas moi
qui s'est plaint le massage de sport
m'intéresse moins mais le ski avoir
journée de ski c'est fantastique c'est
le macabre de revenir après juridique et
grand-père ou par contemporain art
contemporain ça c'était notre je dirais
les questions cette offre presque set up
parce que ma fille a fait ses études
dans leurs contemporaines donc j'ai
appris beaucoup en lisant sa maîtrise
qu'elle avait crevé crime et sur ça on a
changé tous les ordres dans nos maisons
avec leurs contemporaines j'ai assisté à
plusieurs des événements au musée d'art
contemporaine et au musée 2
musée d'art de montréal mais a donc à
contemporaine musique classique jazz gas
gas et en classe pour la musique
classique que dans ma vie mais le jazz
sera plus content je dirais véhicule
utilitaire sport auto sport des cultes
sport durant et elle était tellement
courbe qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
avoir une décapotable
ce n'est pas nécessairement une mauvaise
chose pendant deux mois
les prochaines jeunes aiment beaucoup
des nôtres en bunny 102
certaines de ces questions de qu'il faut
répondre
est ce que je peux répondre non au
diable je dirais que ne savaient pas
aucune de ces réponses parce que je
pense que les deux extrêmes de changer
la structure les états unis de la façon
que ce soit monsieur saint loup monsieur
trame de prendre le faire c'est pas
quelque chose que je partage un bus et
c'est dramatique donc je pense pas qu'on
serait en meilleure position ni avec
l'un ni avec la poutine ou filet mignon
filet mignon qu'il est mignon c'est une
question que peut poser ma femme parce
que là toutes sortes de demandes
concernant la nourriture que je mange
le repas au restaurant ou à la maison à
la maison à la maison maintenant j'ai
mangé trop au restaurant depuis
plusieurs années comme me disait un de
mes yeux mes amis accord faisant ce
qu'on fait on parle de trait à talons
dans de petits déjeuners déjeuners et
souper plutôt qu'autre chose
l'assurance et dans tous les toits au
restaurant préféré à la maison
maintenant viandes poissons légumes
pression poisson façon
d'autres végétaux non livres ou
tablettes table est peut-être la
meilleure réponse aurait été libre mais
tablettes que je peux pas vraiment me
sens à ma table maintenant classe
économique aux classes affaires écoutez
leur il faut que les gens suspend notre
classe affaires parce que on ne continue
même avec des produits de loisirs ont
continué à pousser nos classes a peur
des gens comme vous vous devriez
certainement utiliser notre cas se faire
comme moi avec des rabais avec lui c'est
merci à vous merci beaucoup regrettent
les héros